welcome to see I'm playing a nicmar 11
from the US we have again a rather big
rating mismatch okay splaying the co-ceo
variation of the way I think 93 is an
interesting way to play against that one
point is that g6 is now answered by by
deform is this is the position I wonder
yeah I think I think this is the whole
point isn't it and now 95 m
is this dumb they up sometimes there are
those those tricks there are those
tricks with them 94 now night just just
just for fun 94 bishop d for Queen D 494
Knight f6 check King f8 Bishop h6
checkmate hmm there are various ways to
get to this to this type of to get this
type of play but 94 here you can just
take with the night and it's it's really
completely pointless Bishop Bishop g5
might be might be a possible a team
no maybe Bishop g5 him and on age six I
play Bishop f6 is playing this rather
quickly probably this is a known
position and well known to him and not
to me now they think he needs to take
now on f6 yeah castles are played Bishop
c6 and just when I must do that Bishop
have 69 f6 checking evade and then then
what 94 King g7 something like that I
know maybe I don't know the line i made
this 97 is playable it has been played
by some good good players recently he's
on zocalo for example and even a wrong
young once in a while mostly and then
rapid and blitz chess but he he played
it hmm now maybe I should have thought
about that a bit what what am I playing
against hmm against King g7 yeah of
course I can play 95 but after Knight
takes ed rupee 8 i'm not i'm not happy
now 94 was very stupid why on earth did
i do that i can get it back anyway at
any given time i don't i don't see what
i should do now how do hmm how do i play
now it does not have a good squares my
problem and we as mentioned 95 night
takes ed rookie eight there should be
two Knight takes Queen 2x check we have
six it's like simply and maybe I can do
that can come on let's do let's do it
let's do it I can what I can try us 90 x
ed night a rookie a check Bishop e2 9424
Queen f6 takes King takes d6 this might
be might be something I can try okay is
going for something else now if I take
you can even take with the pawn and at
the end now why I need to go back here
like Bishop c60 c90 727 and my phone
hangs very bad but I didn't mind that
yet now I need to needed to get get this
from off from be five anyway b5 wasn't a
good a good place anymore so this piece
now maybe I could have played Bishop c4
though maybe down maybe
yeah but black should should be okay
yeah i mean you can just go GCM d6 for
example and then try to treat rate every
everything off rook e8 something like
that yeah ok this is also possible just
exchange everything but at the end of
all this now he has a slightly worse
version of that and i have this move and
this is important if you would be able
to play d6 himself black would be in
perfect perfect shape and now this this
is this however is a different animal
let's let's be let's try to be precise
iam how do I make sure that his Bishop
is not getting into play ok I can attack
d 6 which can be covered with rook t1 or
long castles but he will move the pawns
like b5 and and and and moves like that
should I play a form a me yeah it makes
some sense
and now I can go away five yeah this is
okay and now he must take the only move
or rock p8 this is this is losing
straight away he is never going to play
c5 now I think because of this and maybe
I can't play book be a gyro PA din c5
now does this even holds this move into
question now I was playing this far too
quickly I mean b5 was really really bad
but I played this too quickly no es
rookie 6 also okay well this is this is
forced anyway and he must play rugby
Aiden be on c5 trying to to get this
disordered
I'll bet rookie 5 preparing c5 is also a
move that might be helpful look be a
droopy 5 than c5 you have my pawn moves
before I was stupid before Bishop e3 was
really very stupid now the problem is
this look on h1 it's not playing and
they don't really see how to get it into
play it's all very slow like GE three
king g2
yeah good news
not just repaired it's there any way to
to prevent that not really ah what a
shame to get it back yeah I really have
yeah after d60 here this position black
is just straight lost and then let's let
him into the game again I just played
this far too far too superficially
hmm hmm i don't i don't really see a
good move him
okay mommy takes takes Rukia Cecchini to
rookie 6 this like there is no good way
to sac apanya really for activity I
don't see how aunty will play rock v8
and this is not even equal I mean I'm
worse this is this is the bad thing it's
not like a spice body to a draw
something it's just just a bad position
for me
maybe I can try look to see three or
something rook c8 Roxy rugby a drug c3
and if he goes rook e8 i move the jeep
on but it's a very shaky rookie one
checking g2 takes takes rook e1 checked
in g2 and he can attack it from behind
and then I maybe have rookie 337 trying
to yeah maybe maybe something like that
ah but I'm struggling in this position
that's really awful yeah then our oops
III was my idea
you can play rookie six
or King music's really wow and this I
don't believe oh it's that trick I don't
I don't see it Bishop e7 takes on before
I've Roxy seven okay I need to take
anyway now maybe you can even play that
I mean I'm so bad developed Roxy five
take stakes and then before or something
or the king I probably need to take with
the rocker
yeah I probably need to take with the
rook rook takes and then King is 65 he
just approaches with the King and I
don't see how i stopped that rocked a
group takes be takes King sex king a
king g5 he just picks the picks up picks
up them he just picks up the pawns so
this is maybe not one hundred percent
clear as I can I always have this of the
deep on with some some technical ideas
Here I am jegs rook takes I'd threaten a
six and a half the d7 idea maybe
I'm playing without the rukon h1 I hate
it I hate it maybe you can play look t5
here threatening rookie one mate this is
possible he could move ok didn't do it
ok I go now come on take it come let's
take it may be this seven what I'm just
too frustrated him take a six you can
take a five now at least I'm not worth
any more I'd i think but i have no way
to keep the pawn right yeah well i play
without the ropes on any way to to not
ok so what now it's it's completely
equal
ok let's seems there any anything I can
try yeah well its got rotate who I
wanted to go to d3 of course give me
some Mouse lips that even lose it again
it was highly critical reform at least
now it's a draw but make a couple of
mouse lips I might even managed to lose
it King III is really completely
completely completely moronic move f5 f5
is a strange one it does not really help
him yeah but what am i doing with the
sepal I mean this is the sea point is
really really oh goodness here maybe I
can protect it from the from the from
the back f5 wow really I didn't expect
that well it's now well ok let's let's
check it briefly now they rotate from
Genesis
it's not good I mean it's probably not
losing but certainly not helping to win
but I still want to try of course I want
to use this yes we can dispense with f5
maybe uk6 is something that that can
help me
can i play starting with move around
move 70 now this is really I really
should be punished for that so that at
the end I couldn't even use my h1 Rock
unbelievable okay so what is this not
sure what is playing now to be honest
this is maybe just give the check Sam
will be five or something
yeah but it's not clearly it's not so
apparent what you should do now to
really force a draw yeah yeah now i can
give the check now and this then then
trading hmm this might might be tricky
ok six check oopsie six texts ex-king be
for King be five at the end I'm going to
see for King be five and it's not
winning it's not winning really and if I
give the check and detection I get the
check I almost I'm forced to trade ok
let's protect it first looks III it's
not helping him just go to d2 you can go
can go give this check here then I just
go back and then see if I find a better
move
roop ki five I might go to see far
though yeah rocked it to book before I
can I have this check and taped yourself
it is a drive it's still a draw but
that's just just just repeat for a
moment it does not it's not it's not a
big deal and now he's what is it doing
playing for we know what and now i can't
go f4 and give the check out hmm should
I am now it only should that's a weird
decision I could you could have just rip
repeated so I know it gets gets
problematic and it's just this is lost
winning the beep on now okay I could
slip like King f7 with the draw
oh this was really tricky yeah I made my
the made it heart hard for myself ooh
what's the easiest yeah just just take
him and get there get the King into play
yeah it's super Swank no he loses the g
point or the h-bond yeah yeah nice left
the f porn fortunately check black
resign yeah but this is a prime example
of a really terrible play with what I
did here after this black is in in
really bad shape i mean maybe maybe I'm
overestimating things I don't know now
the comp has a good to the good defense
yeah rupee ADC 7b six and then rook 877
white being better but not decisive but
after that I can't believe it I mean
look at this this bishop but what I did
is just plain terrible this maybe maybe
but I can I should just I should just
castle the question is long or short
maybe this isn't so so good and yeah the
problem is that the d6 pawn it also
needs a bit of support and he always has
rookie a droopy 6 and b5 Bishop e7 maybe
this isn't so bad i overestimated this I
thought black is in really bad shape and
it's not so bad but I need to I need to
do something like that justjust for
example but now my piece is play I mean
something like that should be is
something but what I did him in terrible
I mean tier mecham f4 Bishop e3 maybe
but this this is just unspeakable now is
threatening see if I I'm just not
developed here Black is just just
clearly better here it's a it's a
question what's the best move or the
rugby aid maybe first and I mean black
is just clearly clearly better maybe he
can just you can also just maybe play
rookie 6 King e5 and get the born this
is this was really kini 6cm wins
probably you know yeah this was wasn't
necessary at all it's still it's still
good good for black yeah he could he
could take of course and then I need to
play the Jeep or try to hang on but I'm
just worse clearly worse
gjermund after that he allowed louder
drawn position get this was a mouse
lipid probably not it's not a fatal one
yeah the rook trade is not helping and
yeah black and black and draw in various
ways this is just not necessary because
he now after that he must play this of
course and after Luke b6 Luke c5 it is
still a draw but it was necessary to get
the King back but how I don't know how
he could could play that he had four
minutes on the clock and this is very
very apparent that that black is losing
the beep on yeah this was a very very
lucky very lucky game what I want to
show you briefly as though the tactical
thing that that I was mentioning just
it's not it's not a good move but just
to show you the idea if black takes like
this there's Queen D for ya me this is a
typical trick
very funny funny checkmate the problem
is that he can just take here and this
is not I can play Bishop g5 here honey
enough so maybe I can take he i am the
an-94 is not right this is right i mean
age 6 this takes takes and here here
here of course this is a mistake this is
a mistake just too early i need to time
this better maybe maybe this one I let
them know of course here it's an
interesting the computer wants to go
here which is an interesting move with
this point I'm very cute white is better
now I took it took it to her took it too
quickly also and tae even has this this
this funny reply leading to good play
interesting so I game with many mistakes
of course here you could have gotten a
better version of the game this long
this is also totally equal I cannot I
don't even have a d6 idea here just
place this kind of movement end is equal
ok Jen went around toi but it was an
interesting game you never should have
lost that really very lucky at the end
ok thanks for watching